Guatemalan mother says her baby died
after falling ill and a Texas
immigration facility and now she is
planning to sue the US government border
agents apprehended Yasmine Juarez and 19
month old Maria in March after they
entered this country seeking asylum
Juarez blames inadequate medical care in
the facility for her baby's death six
and a half weeks later
Mireya Villarreal is in Los Angeles with
growing concerns over conditions for
detainees Maria good morning well good
morning 20 year-old Yasmine wadis fled
from Guatemala with her daughter because
she feared for their safety but she
never imagined that her dream of coming
to the US would end up like this and now
she's not only seeking millions of
dollars in several lawsuits she's asking
for justice for her only child she had
an amazing smile and chubby cheeks she
had never had any serious medical
conditions or any chronic medical
conditions of any kind she was a she was
a healthy kid lawyers for Yasmine Juarez
say her daughter Maddy a was examined
and cleared for custody by medical staff
at the South Texas family residential
center in March
what is his lawyer Stanton Jones says
within days the toddler developed a
respiratory infection after sharing a
room with other children some of whom
were sick what started with a cough and
congestion and runny nose turned into
intermittent fevers sometimes spiking as
high as over a hundred and four degrees
lawyers say medical staff prescribed an
antibiotic tylenol and honey among other
treatments but Maddie's health continued
to decline the medical care that Maddie
a received inside daily was woefully
inadequate neglectful and substandard
legal papers filed Tuesday say ma DA was
still sick when she and her mother were
released to live with family in New
Jersey hours later the child was
admitted to the hospital six and a half
weeks later ma DA died it was
unimaginably painful for as mean lawyers
say Maddie a suffered irreversible brain
and organ damage ice declined to comment
on Maria's case due to pending
litigation
but in a statement the agency says it
takes very seriously the health safety
and welfare of those in our care
including providing access to necessary
and appropriate medical care
she has mean justice means more than
just money nothing can ever bring her
daughter back but she wants to make sure
that this never happens again
lawyers for Yasmin are preparing several
lawsuits the first is seeking 40 million
dollars in damage from the city in
Arizona that is the prime contractor for
that Detention Center in Dili Texas we
reached out to the lawyers for that city
but have yet to hear back from them
Norah disturbing all those details Matea
thank you very disturbing I love that
she has a lawyer that she's pursuing
this because just a phrase unimaginably
unimaginably painful to lose your
daughter and it's like you're caught up
in a system that really clearly has some
flaws the system that wasn't prepared
for this exactly John it's heartbreaking